there's a mountain of rumors and reports
out there about a new ps4 but now sony
has officially confirmed that the
console exists I'm Tony and this is your
upgraded gamespot news update the more
powerful ps4 codename neo is totally
real as Sony's Andrew house confirmed to
the Financial Times the system features
improved graphics and 4k resolution
support that's all house confirmed but
he did specify that the new console is
meant to quote complement the standard
ps4 and that Sony will continue to sell
both versions of the hardware he also
stated that all games will continue to
run on the original ps4 and most if not
all will also be compatible with the Neo
Sony's e3 press conference seems like
the perfect time to give more details
about the Neo but the console will not
be present at the convention no price
point or release date has been announced
either for now all we can do is wait for
Sony to say more but if you want to stay
up to date on all the PlayStation news
you're already in the right place